[Music]
so baby mm-hmm
why are you reading that what do you
mean do you want to start swinging or
something
it's know about swingers that's such a
difficult like way of looking at it it's
about love like Polly many memory love
like many loves the idea that you can
just love more than one person it's not
about swingers parties you can love more
than one person yeah I don't know but
that's like that's what it's talking
about
and I think that's actually quite
amazing Jeremy it's quite generous
instead of this idea that we could be
fixated on like possessing one person
and we're a jealous all the time it's
actually probably a way more mature
open-minded way of living our lives it
just sounds a bit sleazy
it's not sleazy it's the opposite it's
Noble this enlightened the premises that
capitalism has taught us that lovers are
objects we own rather than gifts we
could share and so once we realized that
we've been tricked into being possessive
and jealous we can be elevated to a
higher plane why'd you have to [ __ ]
everyone you can't just be friends with
people so without [ __ ] everyone you
see with some people and that can be an
expression of love the highest
expression of love okay let me get it
straight then so you get to bang a
select range of people
Roisin gets to bang a select range of
people and then you both justify it in
terms of this salad of ancient Greek
philosophy Buddhist thought and hippie
nonsense and we're meant to think that
you're going to be amazing and it's
hunky-dory and no one gets hurt and all
the pain and agony that we felt in
relationships is just a two
thousand-year-old mistake that we've
been making the whole time it sounds
amazing how long do you give you
relationship
such a cynic no open your mind
shut your legs I'm not being cynical I'm
saying you're just giving an excuse for
not being able to commit to one person
it does sound very interesting I think
it's beautiful really because I love
Jason so much and yet suddenly there's
this huge space for honesty really but
have either of you met anyone yeah yeah
you have well no no but in a
hypothetical sense you know there is
time hypothetically no I knew it
not like nothing proper but something
like little tiny have you told Jason yes
yeah well I haven't told Jason but you
know if he asks I'll tell him because
that's what it's about radical honesty
so you and lo have had sex oh I knew I
knew you were going to ask that
and it's really missing the point what
so addictive I don't think I don't think
I'm missing the point
[Music]
you can look at it look at it later this
fight big Lou Everett I do later believe
my pastor looks ready so so they've said
that the project has to go through the
man our office which means we could pick
it up again in spring which is actually
good for the guys in London because
obviously Dayton that's wrong baby
you
[Music]
yeah I don't know I think maybe I'm just
too weak or insecure but I don't know I
love you and I don't want to show you
and maybe I do want to own you but if I
can never sleep with anyone else for the
rest of my life I think I prefer that
than losing you and I don't know maybe
that's normal maybe it's not normal I
don't know no screw it it doesn't work
for us it doesn't work for us love the
books
[Music]
I love that guy
sir I think you look a bit like him
really yeah I mean he's like a morbidly
obese version you do that sometime
someday so did anything happen with some
you know look it's all about it yeah
mm-hmm-hmm we do oh there again stop
this
[Music]
love is a skill that we can learn our
relationships book calmly guides us with
calm and charm through the key issues of
relationships to ensure that success in
love need not be a matter of good luck
for more click the link now